para nosotros es momento de ir en
directo a Brasil porque ahí se produjo
un nuevo ataque en una escuela que dejó
una estudiante muerta y a otro herido de
gravedad los hechos ocurrieron en el
municipio de cambé esto es en el norte
de Paraná conectamos ahora con nuestra
corresponsal Valeria sakone Valeria qué
detalles tenemos
la violencia ha vuelto a matar en una
escuela de Brasil esta vez ha sido en el
sur del país en el estado del Paraná un
ex alumno de 21 años se rompía esta
mañana en una escuela y mataba a tiro a
una joven de 17 años e iría a otro joven
de 16 años que está ingresado en estado
grave sabemos que los dos jóvenes las
dos víctimas eran novios y que el
asesino ha sido arrestado las
autoridades han informado que además de
armas han encontrado un cuaderno con
anotaciones de otras masacres escolares
entre ellas la célebre masacre de la
ciudad de susano en el estado de San
Pablo que en 2019 se saldó con siete
víctimas además los familiares del joven
han informado que el chico es
esquizofrénico y que estaba siendo
tratado por su enfermedad hoy a primera
hora de la mañana también el presidente
Luis Ignacio luna de da si a punto de
viajar a Europa por su nueva gira ha
condenado los actos y ha mostrado su
solidaridad para la familia lo mismo ha
hecho el ministro de Educación y por su
parte el gobernador del estado del
Paraná ha decretado un luto de tres días
Valeria y este es el quinto ataque en
una escuela en Brasil en lo que va de
año Cómo se explica esta cifra
los principales expertos de Brasil
apuntan a dos causas para explicar la
escalada de la violencia en las escuelas
de Brasil por un lado la proliferación
de armas durante el mandato de Jair
bolsonaro cuando más de un millón de
armas llegaron a manos de coleccionistas
cazadores y tiradores deportivos gracias
a las nuevas leyes el gobierno de Lula
ha lanzado una campaña para registrar de
nuevo todas las armas tener un control y
evitar que esas armas estén en manos de
personas peligrosas o que circulen de
forma ilegal Pero hay otra causa sería
el efecto emulación potenciado gracias a
las redes sociales hemos visto en este
caso del Paraná con el cuaderno que
llevaba el asesino por esta razón los
principales medios de comunicación de
Brasil han alcanzado un acuerdo para no
revelar la identidad de los autores de
esas masajes escolares y así reducir su
fama y por otra parte el el resto de los
diputados está discutiendo un proyecto
de ley que quiere obligar a las grandes
plataformas a realizar una verdadera
moderación de los contenidos violentos
en las redes sociales y también de la
publicidad asociada a la violencia por
un lado las grandes plataformas como
Telegram o Google están haciendo campaña
contra el gobierno de Lula Por otra
parte los bolsonaristas y en general los
liberales le acusan de querer implantar
una censura pero los principales
expertos en tecnología en sociología
dicen que si Brasil consigue aprobar
esta ley estaría en la vanguardia
mundial en lo que es moderación y
control de los contenidos violentos en
internet